bonsoir emmanuel bierre merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt front gérald
darmanin qui a donc a reçu on l'a dit
c'est représentant les organisations et
associations est ce que vous y avez
participé aujourd'hui si oui quelles
conclusions tirez-vous
mais bon soir bien sûr j'y ai participé
en tant que secrétaire général du snj
cgt
il me semble que là ce que vous venez de
dire de montrer de la députée république
en marche qui ose affirmer enfin que
nous allons tranquillement vers un état
autoritaire voilà c'est monsieur d'arman
nous a donné une fin de non recevoir
donc nous nous avons pris nos
responsabilités nous sommes dans une
coordination qui regroupe 70
organisations beaucoup plus large
d'ailleurs que les syndicats de
journalistes 1 il ya aussi la ligue des
droits de l'homme amnesty international
il ya beaucoup d'organisations de la
société monsieur darmanin n'a pas voulu
nous entendre
ça fait quatre ans que spécifiquement
les journalistes ont des problèmes avec
les forces de l'ordre lors des
manifestations
c'est le troisième ministre de
l'intérieur que nous voyons nous avons
d'abord vu monsieur cazenave en 2016
monsieur castaner en 2018 maintenant
monsieur d'arman il n'y a toujours pas
de réponses à nos interrogations et
surtout maintenant il c'est une
véritable crise de défiance entre la
profession de journaliste est en tout
cas le ministère de l'intérieur et le
mini dans l'intérieur puisque nous pour
nous monsieur permanent n'est plus ce
soir notre interlocuteur et nous en
appelons à monsieur castex emmanuel vire
à votre avis c'est pour cette raison
cette mésentente cette fin de
non-recevoir qu'on entend ce blocage que
gérald darmanin a passé la conférence de
presse attendu ce soir qu'il avait prévu
que c'est évidemment on a bien on a bien
senti nous en étant présent sur place
que monsieur monsieur darmanin allait
essayer d' instrumentaliser cette
rencontre alors qu'il faut savoir c'est
déjà c'est une rencontre que nous
demandons depuis des mois des mois des
mois avant la publication du nouveau
schéma de maintien de l'ordre qui est
intervenue le 16 septembre
et je vous rappelle par exemple que
l'interpellation de notre confrère de
france télévisions lors de notre
première mobilisation mardi
n'est pas dû à la loi là nous la
nouvelle proposition de loi sécurité
globale c'est bien un effet du nouveau
schéma de maintien de l'ordre
mis en place par monsieur darmanin le 16
septembre
comment vous expliquez qu'il vous reçoit
finalement la veille de l'adoption de la
loi par l'assemblée nationale ça
n'aurait pas de lui est concerné un
petit peu avant en amont évidemment
c'est ce que nous lui avons dit il a
essayé si vous voulez pendant la réunion
d'en faire un problème spécifique des
syndicats turna liste des représentants
du journaliste avec le pouvoir
on n'en est plus là malheureusement nous
ça fait des mois je vous dis on l'avait
même demandé à monsieur castaner quand
il ya eu les problématiques de violences
pendant les manifestations de gilet
jaune aujourd'hui peut pas nous dire et
j'ai vu sa déclaration qu'il a fait pour
remplacer la conférence de presse sur
twitter en disant qu'il était très
attaché à la liberté de la presse
mais n'est ce pas le même ministre de
l'intérieur qui a réclamé un floutage
des policiers tout le temps encore il ya
une dizaine de jours
donc quel est ce double discours de
monsieur d'harmonie je pense que la
pression de la rue commence à faire
réfléchir de monsieur d'harmonie mais
nous pour nous c'est trop tard c'est
maintenant à vision 4x
quand on voit les difficultés dans la
majorité de la république en marche
c'est un monsieur castex d'arbitré et de
recevoir la coordination
alors ce qui pose problème on le
rappelle c'est cet article 24 dont on
parle beaucoup qui entend pénaliser la
diffusion malveillante de photographies
policiers lors de manifestations ça
voudrait dire que les journalistes
pourront filmer mais pas diffuser c'est
de ça qu'il s'agit bien sûr mais c'est
surtout une fois de plus un risque même
d'autocensure des journalistes fins et
ont mais on n'arrête pas de mettre des
pressions sur les journalistes
c'est déjà un métier difficile et nous
ne disons pas que le métier de policier
n'est pas difficile sauf que en cas
d'atteinte et c'est ce que dit la
députée république en marche que vous
avez cités avant en cas d'atteinte quand
on veut porter atteinte à un policier
quand on porte atteinte à un policier
que ce soit par des films a remis tout
ça est déjà prévue par le code pénal
donc pourquoi en rajouter pour nous
c'est une pression supplémentaire sur le
libre exercice
du métier de journaliste un métier qui
est déjà mis sous pression depuis des
années par de multiples lois que ce soit
la loi sur le secret des affaires
la loi sur les faits que news ce que ce
soit les journalistes convoqués pour
qu'on essaie de de connaître leurs
sources
enfin on le sent bien et ce qu'on a
essayé de dire au ministre aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il regarde l'image de la france
à l'étranger
enfin bientôt à comparer la france à la
turquie à la hongrie on ne comprend plus
en tout cas la loi a suscité des
manifestations le conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu qui s'interroge sur le
contenu de cette loi la commission
européenne ce et se réserve le droit de
vérifier la conformité du texte avec le
droit de l'union européenne ça fait
beaucoup
sans compter les critiques effectivement
des médias selon vous le gouvernement
peut-il tout même reculer sur cette
forme de pression
après pour nous c'est notre volonté est
de toute façon en tout cas le combat
contre la proposition de loi à sécurité
doré sera long parce que comme vous le
savez demain c'est une adoption à
l'assemblée nationale puis le texte
partira au sénat puis il y aura une
saisine du conseil constitutionnel parce
que les les groupes parlementaires de
gauche de l'opposition ont déjà annoncé
qu'ils saisiraient le conseil
constitutionnel
donc pour nous nous sommes au début
d'une mobilisation et d'ailleurs qui va
se traduire puisque la réunion
d'aujourd'hui est un échec total
monsieur darmanin a pas plu nous entend
donc nous appelons samedi 28 novembre
samedi prochain à des mobilisations
partout en france nous allons organiser
des marches pour la liberté
merci manuel vire secrétaire général snj
cgt d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
rt france pour parler toujours de cette
loi sécurité merci à vous